on top of that same with the fat thing I
say hey men don't like fat chicks then
I'm arguing with these guys because
they'll be like hey I like a woman with
a little something something and I'm
like okay but you know you don't like a
girl with a big waist you like slim
waist big butt like let's just call
somebody Spade why am I arguing like
this like it's so frustrating when you
you're arguing something with someone
who knows it's true or hey you don't
like I know I'm like younger women and
women over 30 it's not their first pick
and they'll argue hey I date some women
over 30. you know I like my women
intellectually whatever the men don't
give a about how smart you are I
mean maybe a little bit but you know it
starts with looks